there is no minimalist rulebook well
until now the minimalists have created
16 rules for living with less a free
ebook which you can download right now
at the minimalists comm slash resources
enjoy minimalist s' hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're gonna talk about
consumerism we're gonna talk about the
successes and failures of modern society
we're gonna talk about the price of
progress and we're gonna talk about
whether civilization has actually made
us less civilized and we're gonna do all
of that with today's guest dr.
Christopher Ryan is here Chris Ryan
author
well let me say author of a couple books
but this new book let me to say
something about your new book Chris by
the way thank you for being here Chris's
new book is called civilized to death
which isn't just a great title there may
be six books that I wish I would have
written and this is definitely on that
list of six the freedom the Shades of
Grey no freedom by Jonathan brands my
life there there there you know
hillbilly elegy by JD Vance is is
amazing there are just a few books that
I I i really wish like the circle by
Dave Eggers is another one that I wish I
would have written because like you
communicate in this book civilize to
death and we'll talk more about the book
I just wanted to give you a compliment
at the top you encourage people to check
out civilized death it just came out
it's really great I own three copies in
fact I don't here I'm gonna hold up
Jordan I'm gonna hold a copy of our book
minimalism and you're gonna superimpose
on the YouTube video this is this is
Chris's book right here I'm sure
an image it has a great cover I don't
have my copy here because my wife stole
my copy although I have three copies
naughty Mariah stole my copy I have
three copies I have the e-book copy I'm
on my Kindle app I've got the audiobook
version because you want that right
tangentially speaking yeah and I was
talking to my doctor my doctor listens
to your podcast really yes he's great
Chris Kelly and we were talking about it
and you have some really fascinating
guests on your podcast from all walks of
life you just stumble across random
people at a bar or in some random town
in Montana and you're like hey do you
want to be on my podcast and you're able
to like carry the conversation on but
here's the but I have my doctor I both
agreed on this he in fact he's the one
who brought it up he goes Chris's
podcast is the one podcast where I want
to hear less of the guests and I just
want to hear more Chris Ryan I feel the
in fact the episode I just put up
yesterday I apologize for talking too
much because when I was doing the mix I
saw like my track it's just like damn
like come on I let the guest talk you
know but thank you for saying that but I
do these Roma episodes
yeah those are to get it out of my
system yeah they're so good man and so
I'm gonna do my best today to shut up as
much as possible
I've encouraged folks to check out
civilize to death check out Chris Ryan's
podcast let's dive into some of these
questions right away our first question
is from Christie in st. Louis Missouri
my name is Christie I'm from st. Louis
Missouri I was just at work reading a
bunch of articles about Amazon's new
products that they're releasing like the
echo microwave and Alexa in your car and
everything and it was just mind-blowing
to me that our society has become lazy
enough to where we don't even want to
press buttons to cook a potato we have
to have a voice oh good potato so I was
wondering about your guys thoughts on
that is because to me is mind blowing
and everybody seems super excited about
it but I just can't believe this is
where we came as a society Alexa kill
Ryan nicodemus calling Ryan Nicodemus
Chris what do you think I mean some of
these advances aren't really advances
even though they report to be yeah in
fact a lot of them are going in the
wrong direction yesterday I told my
phone I won't say the words cuz it would
trigger everybody's phones take me to
Trader Joe's and it called Joe Rogan
instead Mele says so many of these
things are sold to us as advances
they're gonna make life more convenient
they're gonna make life better but as we
find again and again and again that goes
the opposite direction right and I
remember you guys probably aren't old
enough but I remember when the internet
started I remember the first cell phones
you know I saw some guy with a holster
walking down the street with his the
first cell phone oh you're the coolest
guy yeah all these things are supposed
to make life better they have it yet we
have so much free time now don't we
right everybody's just lying around in
hammocks with all that time that these
conveniences have brought about we
talked about that in the book to you you
talked about who's the guy who had the
theory that once technology gets us to a
certain point we were only gonna have to
work 15 hours a week or 20 hours a week
oh yeah yeah I forget the author a
well-known author that I quoted there
that was like a hundred years ago he was
looking into the future and how great
everything's gonna be but but in fact
what happens is these technological
advances could be used to make us work
to allow us to work less and to spread
resources more equitably but in fact
they keep being employed to increase
productivity right thereby reducing the
value of labor right so when you look at
these statistics saying you know the US
worker is five times more productive and
then 10 years ago yeah but he's not
being paid five times as much right so
what they're doing is they're they're
putting these robots in and you know
more technological
assist in the manufacturing process and
they're firing people so we see on a
global scale how this works it's not
helping people and we see on a personal
level how it works as well I can't talk
on my damn cell phone I can't hear the
person I remember when phones had cords
attached to them and you could hear the
person on the other side even when you
do radio interviews now they're like can
you use a landline phone and I'm right
wait what is that how am I gonna find a
landline we didn't experiment we do
these screen las' Saturdays from time to
time where we just put our phone in a
drawer try to find a payphone now it's
virtually impossible right yeah and so
yes we have progressed and some of these
so you're not there's a misconception
here you're not anti progress but I
think the thesis of your book if there
is one is that many of the ways that we
are progressing are not aiding our
happiness or joy or satisfaction or
fulfillment in fact they're getting in
the way of it so yes I mean some
technological advances yeah if you're
gonna cook your potato it's probably
better to have an oven or maybe even a
microwave than it is till I try to
figure out to start a fire with a piece
of Flint so for us like there is a level
of technology that is helpful but then
there is a level of technology that does
make us a bit complacent yeah and
reliant on the technology in a way that
actually disconnects us from our
humanity yeah I mean if these things
were invented for like people with
disabilities I think that's great like
the voice-activated thing Alexa is great
for you know people who who that really
truly adds value to their life but I
feel like yes this is these types of
inventions are leading us towards that
wall-e scenario where we're like sitting
in the chair and everything is just kind
of given to us and yeah it totally
creates complacency yeah in the book and
civilized to death I tell a story about
the greatest shower I ever took yeah it
was in Nepal and I'll never forget it
I'd been trekking for a couple days I
was sweaty way up in the mountains and
and I got to this little village and it
was a situation there were no showers
and so there's a little fire and I put
the pot like a spaghetti
the pot on the fire and I filled it up
with water and then once the water was
hot it took 45 minutes or something to
get their water hot and then I put it in
a bucket and I added enough cold water
that the temperature was just right and
I sort of sponged my pits and you know
dittos and then there was this moment at
the end where I just poured it over my
head and man I almost had an orgasm it
was like oh my god oh good
and like this morning I stepped into the
shower you know turned the lever stood
there thought about something else for a
while
turn it off took no pleasure in it right
and so when we look at the value of life
and the meaning of life and in trying to
judge whether life is better or worse
one of the things that we need to look
at is how much pleasure is in your life
right and how much stress how much
anxiety and men you know I think the
problem with these sorts of
conversations around whether life is
getting better or not and what is
progress and what's the price of
progress we have to figure out what
we're measuring yeah right if we're
measuring convenience there's no doubt a
voice-activated microwave is super
convenient but how much pleasure does it
bring into your life
where are you after that thing enters
your life versus where you were before I
personally take a lot of pleasure from
cooking I love to spend an afternoon
cooking yeah I love that you know to a
simmer soup on a winter afternoon or
bake some bread I'm sure there are
machines that'll do that for me but then
what am I gonna do yeah work its inner
interesting like this balance we had to
find between Lake because if you have
just all pleasure then life is miserable
if you have no pleasure life is
miserable but like tease your shower as
an example it's like life is miserable
with all pleasure
no yeah if it's a hundred percent
pleasure to try that Wow I tell you what
go buy some head go buy some heroin off
the street
heroin will give you pleasure you there
are people buying heroin to to mask the
pain they might be but yeah but I I
think they're using pleasure to mask the
pain though same thing with a sex addict
so go out and you know having sex is
great having sex every five minutes for
you know a week straight that's going to
it's gonna wear on you
I mean you ride about that early
whenever you ride about that in the book
with that whenever we have more than
enough it's always too much and the
there's a line you have about the Rolex
which I love I wrote this down a watch
tells the time a $20,000 Rolex tells
people you've got issues and and that's
so true we have an essay on our website
about a Rolex won't buy you more time
and yet even as one of the minimalists I
am still tantalized by a Rolex
advertiser and I feel as though like
well maybe it's gonna help me signal
that I'm a better person to other people
and it will it'll make me a more
complete or better version of myself and
I think that's with any of these
technologies that we get really caught
up and the object of our desire like
this voice-activated microwave as soon
as that voice-activated thing stops
working it now becomes the object of our
discontent right we're all of a sudden
Siri this morning is telling you the
calling Joe Rogan and it's like well
wait a minute like now you're pissed off
at your the thing that before was
bringing the absolute convenience to you
because as you write about in the book
the hedonic treadmill we adapt to
virtually anything that we bring into
our lives it's why there are so many
highly wealthy people that are just
miserable because they're so used to
getting everything they want and and the
shower their their gold shower stops
working for them for five minutes and
they're really they don't know function
but when you go without a shower but
when you go without a shower for however
long and then you're in the middle of
nowhere and you could just barely get
some warm water yeah it makes that
shower so pleasurable
yeah well it's like food you're gonna
appreciate it more if you're hungry yeah
and and because of this this world of
this artificially created abundance we
never allow ourselves to get hungry and
never allow ourselves to you know get
uncomfortable in any way you know I
wrote about how in my own life you know
I've seen these things happen right like
I used to travel with very little money
backpacking around the world staying in
guest houses and sleeping and you know
kind of if he beds in good cheap places
in India
and yeah it wasn't super comfortable but
I met really interesting people and then
I one in particular I remember is my
birthday and like I must have been 25 26
I decided to splurge and get a nice room
at a big hotel in Cancun on my birthday
and I went up to the room and watched
CNN and the windows wouldn't open and it
was air-conditioned and then I thought
I'll go down to the pool that'll be cool
I went to the pool and it was all these
fat businessmen floating around and it's
like there's nobody here that I want to
talk to this it's a splurging yeah I
just bought myself into misery is what I
did and I see people doing that with
their lives right I wrote about rich
[ __ ] syndrome in the book sort of
tongue-in-cheek a new psychological
problem but what I wanted to do in that
chapter was something I think is pretty
important which is talk about how being
wealthy can make people so unhappy and
it's not that they just don't appreciate
what they have it's that having more
than the people around you
separates you yes and separation is
painful for us whether you're separated
because you're in prison or in solitary
confinement or you're excluded from the
group for some other reason wealth
separates you from your tribe right and
even if you're part of the tribe down at
the golf course or you know the yacht
marina those are all very separate
people because they're all suspicious
you know very wealthy people they're
suspicious why do you want to hang out
with me what's your angle what are you
trying to get do you actually like me or
you just want the money you want access
to this stuff it it's very toxic too
much money too much fame too much power
all these things are toxic yeah and you
talk about in the book about how a lot
of rich people as they get rich they
actually give less then when they made
less money and I think of this
I think the stat and Shawn maybe correct
me if I'm wrong on this but the stat is
South Dakota has roughly the same
population in San Francisco metro area
obviously the number of billionaires is
much higher in San Francisco but South
Dakota gives to charity four times as
much as the people in San Francisco and
it's exactly what you're talking about
it
there are compassion and middle class or
even poor people who have found a way to
to contribute beyond themselves in a
meaningful way but as you acquire more
wealth now in the book you even
acknowledge I throw some people were
able to get past that there are some
compassionate billionaires but they're
more the exception right yeah and you
have to overcome it and there's all that
research - or Keltner I think his name
is does up but Berkeley showing how
increased wealth actually interferes
with your ability to recognize emotions
on another person's face you know I mean
this is really interesting stuff that
happens at very deep levels he did this
one study where he had he posted an old
woman with a walker a cane or something
at a crosswalk and they set up cameras
so they recorded what car stopped and
which cars didn't stop to let her go
right and the more expensive the car the
less likely it was to stop yeah you know
like why is that it's it's we lived in
Missoula for all that time everyone
stops there there there are exactly zero
Aston Martins that's a good it's a good
like example of why I really love to
miss willow Montana is because everyone
stops it there's one thing that that I
didn't like as much about Missoula is
there seemed to be a lack of and maybe
we can talk about actually let's let's
save this I want to talk about ambition
there was seem to be a lack of ambition
there I'm gonna write this down
yeah because we need let's talk about
that later cuz I feel the exact I feel
like there was too much ambition in
Missoula oh no not at all but we can
argue about that maybe we'll save that
for the maximal but Christie I'm gonna
send you a copy of civilized to death I
really hope
you enjoy it our next question is from
Troy and Hartford Connecticut hey guys
this is Troy from Connecticut so I'm 22
years old and I'm trying to start dating
again I found in my first year of adult
life that dating isn't as easy as it
used to be in high school in college I
was constantly surrounded by girls and I
would come with all situations where
relationships just happened but now
those situations are few and far between
I'm not a big fan of dating ask because
I want to meet a person organically I
want things to happen naturally I went
up to a tube cashier at a store one time
and we had a nice conversation in that
conversation and there was me asking for
her phone number and her smiling and her
writing down her number on a piece of
paper I called that number the next day
and found out it was fake and that kind
of scarred me so now I'm scared of
asking out a girl that I've just met in
person so I'm wondering and this is my
question is it weird if I try and ask
out a girl in a way that feels natural
or gonna have to kind of conform to the
times where it's all dating asked or
through Facebook or through interactions
that maybe aren't as natural well we do
have the author of sex it done here oh
boy and so I mean there are certain
dynamics in our culture now that are
wildly different from sort of pre
civilized culture but there are some
taboos here but also Troy's wondering
about you dating apps and and maybe he
wants to do the more traditional way but
a traditional to whom I guess would be
the question what do you think Chris
I've never been on a dating app so I
have no idea I'm aged out of that
demographic for sure
but I think that he touches on something
that's interesting he wants to meet
people organically and when you're in
school it's it happens more because you
just around a lot of women and but the
thing is you're also around people who
have similar interests right you're
taking a sociology class here with
people who might be interested in
sociology presumably right so what I
would encourage him to do and other
young people or older people looking to
meet someone is to put yourself in
situations where you're with people who
have similar interests
so if you like cooking take some cooking
classes you like dancing take some
dancing classes or even if you don't
like those things and you want to learn
about them do that I don't think walking
up to a cashier is the way to do this
yeah because she's getting hit on all
day long yeah she doesn't know anything
about you she doesn't know that all she
knows about you is that you think she's
cute right
which hey everybody thinks she's cute
right so and also the other thing I
would suggest is if you are in a
situation like that where you have a
good vibe with someone I would say give
her your number yes and say give me a
call if you're into it yeah not pushing
her to reveal her privacy and take a
risk on you if she's not feeling it yeah
well like she has to I mean he has to
know that she's open to being hit on and
like to gauge that from a two-minute
interaction when her job is to be
public-facing I mean it's really hard
Troy for you to like really know if she
I mean she may have a boyfriend you know
she may have him she may be married does
have a wedding ring on may be gay right
she may be gay so yeah I love the idea
of giving that like giving the cashier
hurt his number or even an email address
or something like that I mean that's
what's kind of cool about technology is
that you don't have to just get
someone's phone number there's a million
different ways to contact someone that
isn't you know so upfront as a phone
number because a phone number is kind of
personal but I gotta tell you Troy if I
had a dollar for every fake number I got
in my life I mean I'd have a couple
dozen bucks I mean I'm not gonna lie but
here's the thing Troy is like I don't
want to discourage him from asking a
girl out in public I do want to
discourage him from just asking the
cashier out but you know if you run into
someone at the library or the bookstore
and you're hitting it off I mean there's
no there's no there's nothing wrong with
throwing yourself out there but yeah you
can totally do it by giving your number
up but I will say like go out and get
rejected I mean once you get so many
rejections from girls like it becomes
easier and easier to actually talk to
women I feel like I mean you know in a
respectful way it's not like you're just
going out and like machine-gunning like
can I get your number can I get your
number gonna get your yeah you're not
doing the pickup artist thing right I
met my wife at a grocery store yeah and
and you met yours on a dating app yeah
there there there's much to recommend
yeah either one of these our good friend
Matthew Vela who directed our first
documentary he's working on our second
one lessons now he met his wife on
tinder yeah
and so like they're it's okay to embrace
these I mean you say well I want the
more sort of traditional route but well
traditional ten thousand years ago was
you just you know you have an arranged
marriage or like you know you that's
coach someday in some pastors right no
that is absolutely true but I guess like
there's nothing wrong Troy with evolving
with the times and yes I met Mariah who
is like the best relationship romantic
relationship I've ever been in I'm so
happy to have her in my life and I owe
that to OkCupid there's algorithm was
like hey you and this girl are a ninety
three percent match when it comes to
personality and all right today yeah
absolutely is actually probably more
like ninety five percent now cuz I had
some like Christian stuff going on when
I filled that out yeah but uh but yeah
like now I've kind of like moved away
from that so we're even closer but yeah
it was mostly beliefs is where we didn't
kind of match on but the thing is is
like Colin right he's one of our buddies
and he he got he got a gig where he had
to do this article read a beautiful I'm
trying to like not name this company
that hired him to write up this article
but basically they were like look Colin
we want you to go out and try all the
dating apps and then we want you to
write up on our data dating app and
explain what what ours has that the
others doesn't so he did that in a very
genuine way he was like look here's why
this dating app is good and the others
don't have this but he was like secretly
though OkCupid has the best algorithm
and that's the only reason why I got on
there is from his recommendation so Troy
I was like you once I didn't want to get
on a dating app if you were to have told
me in 1998 like you know the year before
I graduated high school hey Ryan you're
gonna meet the love of your life on the
internet I would be like how freaking
desperate am I gonna get yeah but now
with the with technology evolving its it
can be used as a good tool especially in
the dating world and the cool thing is
is like you don't have to go on go on
tinder and just look at it as a meat
market some people do that and they're
just white well there's nothing wrong
with that no no there isn't but but you
know my wife used it has that for a
while yeah
and it's and it's totally okay to do
that but I guess to the point I'm trying
to make though is when you go on these
dating apps Troy which I would recommend
that you do be a hundred percent genuine
if you want to go on there as a meat
market
you know app then great use it as that
be upfront about that if you want to go
on there and meet a you know long-term
romantic partner then be upfront about
that too I mean there are still you know
ways to find genuine people online even
though there might be a little bit of a
little bit of a cesspool on there but uh
but it's totally possible if you're
being yourself Matt Diavel is a great
example where you know he was on tinder
tinder was kind of looked at as the
hook-up app he met his wife on there but
they were both very upfront about like
hey yeah like you know sure we're dating
but I'm really looking for a long-term
partner they had a lot in common and now
they're married I think it's really
important to something I didn't
appreciate until I was well into my 30s
it's how important it is to filter out
incompatible people early yeah so you
don't waste time the fact that a woman's
hot doesn't mean that you're gonna be a
good match with her right right so might
be a good match for about two minutes
yeah but it's not gonna be a fulfilling
relationship
so if if what you're interested in is a
relationship stop thinking about women
in terms of physical attractiveness so
much and go deeper than that and and
pursue relationships with people with
whom you have common interests like that
you would actually want to share your
life with
yeah and that's totally independent of
what someone looks like I couldn't agree
more man when I went on OkCupid I told
myself like I wasn't gonna judge a book
by its cover and Mariah when she reached
out to me she had nothing on her profile
no picture not even a photo nothing she
just looked at and I lucked out yeah
that's right but she was not she was not
the first she was not the first girl who
had messaged me with no profile picture
but I mean just to your point I got so
much more out of that dating up because
I wasn't going for just looks yeah I
mean I really went out of my way to kind
of you know date whoever we when we had
the high percentage you know 80 90 %
range I was I wanna give this a shot no
matter how it
you're probably gonna learn something
interesting from the person enjoy their
company right and if there's not the
chemical attraction right yeah yeah I
think we can use our time so much better
if we just sort of filter out and
getting to your point about rejection
like I've spent most of my adult life
living in Spain right and Spanish
approach to dating and courtship is
quite different from the American
approach in that you know sort of
Spanish Italian man their vibe is that
rejection is expected
oh that's part of it so like this game
yeah it's like a game it's no big deal
and so they'll say something you know to
a woman like you know oh my god you're
so beautiful you would never go out with
a guy like me would you
you know like and and she might laugh
and say well no or maybe I don't know
maybe I'd make an exception or whatever
but it's like reject we're calling it
rejection but it isn't really because as
you said there are a million reasons
that she might not be available right
that have nothing to do with you yeah
and so American guys tend to take this
stuff so personally right mm-hmm which
puts a lot of pressure on her right now
she's feeling like oh my god this guy's
so fragile if I say no it's gonna ruin
his day you know whereas if you're just
like hey I'm confident I'm comfortable
yeah I'd love to have dinner with you
but yeah I understand it's probably not
gonna happen but I just thought I'd ask
that's much easier for her to say yes
actually Yeah right because you're not
putting this heavy sail on her yeah Troy
I'm gonna send you a copy of our book
everything that remains it's my favorite
thing that we've ever written here I'll
hold it up for the YouTube audience but
also my favorite chapter in there is
about a relationship that I really
screwed up and the lessons I learned
from that relationship
the first quote love of my life if we
can call it that and I was actually my I
was after my marriage and I was divorced
at this point but I was dating someone
and really loved her but also forsook
her in several ways and there was a
compatibility there that I didn't
acknowledge and so a lot of lessons
learned throughout that also true I'm
gonna recommend you get Chris brought up
know your interest so you you you can be
compatible some
with similar interests also know your
values a lot of us aren't clear on what
our values are and you can find someone
with similar values if you want to get
clear on your values we just have a new
essay on our website right now it's
called how to understand your values
there's a free worksheet on there so you
can like you can download it and print
it out and fill out what your values are
you can see what mine are my wife and I
we go over this once a year and just
sort of talk about what are your values
it helps me better better understand her
so I can understand how to interact with
her it also helps you better understand
myself so I can figure out how to
interact with other people so we'll put
a link to that in the show notes but you
can also find it at the minimalists comm
/v and i didn't value that just totally
speaks to you and Bex is like a type
personality I don't know where it would
be on the myers-briggs but you're like
alright honey today is planning yeah
today is January 1st do you have your
values worksheet um I'd like to sit down
and compare our indexes like yes honey I
do have my values worksheet we grade it
that's great
9:15 oh we're late we're late check the
calendar sweetheart
all right enjoy that Troy values
worksheet the minimalist comp size
values will send you a copy of
everything that remains as well if you
liked our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of that or if you want
the book book or the e-book we'll send
those to you as well Ryan what time is
it you ready are you ready for the
lightning round we got to hurry quicker
quick all right man this is where we
answer questions from social media
indeed we do we are at the minimalists
on Facebook Twitter and Instagram and
Chris Ryan is at that Chris Ryan you can
follow him as well and what we try to do
here Chris is we try to answer questions
with just a short shareable less than
140 character response little boy but
not really we ramble a little bit yeah
and then Shawn tweeze is something out
makes it beautiful and pithy he puts it
in the show notes so people can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if they like and now you can find all of
our minimal Maxim's in one place minimal
Maxim's com Ryan what's a question
alright April wants to know how much
sacrifice is too much sacrifice I used
to I used to hate this word because it
had this sort of negative connotation
but I think of it now as an is there a
difference between compromise and
sacrifice
No I go ahead I think people say
relationships are a lot of work might be
in the wrong relationship oh really yeah
man but you know it's you know what
though is some pith for you my my
relationship is a lot of work but that's
because of me right yeah so whether
mariah was with me or not I'm constantly
working on myself yeah I mean I I think
relationships certainly are like the the
golden road to maturation and growth if
you're in a good one because your
partner you know challenges your
[ __ ] and questions you'll have
thanks but I ultimately I think these
things should be pleasurable should be
enjoyable you're growing together you're
living together you know people who
fight about every little thing like yeah
move on yeah it's yeah it's that's
that's a toxic relationship and I gotta
tell you like there's so many
relationships I stayed and we were
arguing about so many little things and
it was for the wrong reasons she was
really good looking or the worst was
like I loved her family yeah but I did
not love her so I stayed around for the
family but you know we find these
reasons to stay in these relationships
were arguing about every little thing
and I mean moving on from those
relationships it was tough but hindsight
it's one of the best things I could have
done for myself I think there are three
components to relationships there's
sexual chemistry there's compatibility
and there's love yeah and when I was
younger I used to think love was really
rare and now that I'm older I see love
is everywhere love is the easiest yeah
because you're gonna love everyone and
chemistry is is plentiful as well as the
reason there eight billion people on
this earth is we've found a lot of
chemistry
yeah but compatibilities ruffit's and
rarer and and it's the value thing we
talk about the interests yeah they all
have to align in a way and by the way
you need to be in sort of a similar
space as well so your value your values
might shift over time your interest
certainly will shift over time yeah find
your one piece of advice I keep coming
back to and these are your areas is find
your non-negotiables and then don't
negotiate right right so if you really
want to have kids
don't settle down with someone who
doesn't want to have kids because
someone's gonna be misery
if your non-monogamous and you know that
about yourself don't get into a
monogamous relationship you're gonna end
up hurting yourself and the other
person's misleading it's it's it's false
yeah to thy knows own self be true
you know that line from Hamlet I think
it is and it follows as night follows
the day thou canst not be false to any
man right if you if you're true to
yourself you won't lie to anyone else
it's a beautiful way to put it my pithy
answer real quick is enough is in the
eye of the beholder
yeah and so sometimes I we don't even
stop to ask what enough is and so when
April asks well how much sacrifice is
too much sacrifice I mean I think it's
highly spirt perspectival with respect
to your situation and whether we're
talking about a relationship or with
stuff or you're sacrificing maybe to
work a job to feed your family there's a
certain amount of sacrifice that might
be well it might be appropriate for you
that would be totally inappropriate for
me yeah I pet the answer is there's no
such thing as the perfect amount of
anything and I think we look especially
going down this road of minimalism
people will ask us like oh what's the
perfect amount of things to own what's
the perfect amount of things to give up
and and we got to stop aiming for
perfect and we have to start looking for
balance so if you're sacrificing and
you're finding yourself in a black hole
of depression and of deprivation then
maybe yeah stop sacrificing a little too
much if you're finding yourself
in a world of 100% pleasure to the point
where your level for pleasure has been
raised and you are you know on that
hedonic treadmill then maybe yet maybe
sacrifice a few things to to appreciate
the things that you do have it makes me
think of have you heard about this thing
that they're doing in Silicon Valley now
the dopamine fasts have you heard about
this now so like basically it's this
trend happening right now where you
basically rob yourself of any joy or
anything that would give you dopamine I
don't know what the time limit is sounds
very puritanical right yeah it's really
well it's crazy though is it speaks to
how
the balance is important right it's like
weight a pendulum has swung because it's
it's been hedonism and so I'm gonna give
up who uh we got to introduce you to
Pete Rollins you guys would fall in love
with each other
platonically but or other you know no
judgment the thing he talks about is
like he goes he's a former black pastor
but he he's like a religious heretic and
in a way but the thing he talks about is
he knows like Christian conservatives
who really want to be hippies and he
knows hippies who want to be Christian
conservatives because it becomes this
this pendulum and we feel as though well
hedonism didn't work for me so now I'm
gonna have to never have dopamine in my
life ever again or for this gray area
dove time all right before we get into
our added value segment and our listener
tips today it looks like we have a bunch
more to talk about this week right we've
got so much we're gonna talk about first
we're gonna argue about ambition we'll
have yes dr. Ryan mediate that I hate
when I'm wrong I hate when I'm wrong and
right we're gonna talk about Matthew
Vella and his story of the unfortunate
events that happen at a massage parlor
yeah man and I had something very
similar happen I you know what I can't
talk about in public we'll save it for
the patreon episode yeah we're also
going to talk about is intelligent sexy
or what makes someone sexy Oh Chris is
the author of sex at dawn so we're gonna
talk about that we're gonna talk about
why my wife thinks Chris Ryan is sexy
we're gonna talk about why do humans
form hierarchical societies and why are
we so power-hungry we're gonna talk
about civilization we're gonna talk
about schizophrenia and how some people
around the world actually hear good
voices when they're schizophrenic yeah I
find that to be really fascinating we're
gonna talk about love and compatibility
we're gonna talk about how Christopher
Columbus was a total psychopath and why
he was a psychopath we're gonna talk
about man with so many other things
vaccines vaccinate our kids should we do
it should we not do it
stay tuned oh and another four things
you need to know about vaccines in this
week's patreon episode
also Chris Ryan was really gonna take on
Richard Dawkins and Steven Pinker in a
way that I've never heard anyone take
him on before he does such a great job
and so so much more one of the best
conversations I've ever had with dr.
Christopher Ryan so if you want to hear
all that I look and I love how we can
just like record random conversations
and make something out of it yes I feel
like the conversation we had like that's
if we were at dinner we would just be
having that conversation absolutely yeah
yeah so if you want to hear all that you
can listen to this week's maximal
episode available exclusively on patreon
I'm not gonna go through the whole spiel
this week just know that if you do
become a patron then you can play our
podcast episodes our private podcast
episodes in your regular podcast app
it's just 2 bucks if you really want to
help us out keep us 100% advertisement
free and listen to this week's
conversation with dr. Christopher Ryan
probably the best conversation you're
gonna hear all month it's the best
conversation I've had this is a great
great combo yes indeed so should we
should we tell them that if they become
a patreon subscriber that they could be
they could live a complete life and have
happiness at their grips what and have
all the pleasures all right yeah if you
do want to listen to that and all of our
100-plus private podcast episodes you
can do so over the minimalists comm
slash support Ryan what else you got for
us this week I got some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
check them out hey Joshua and Ryan this
is Adam from Massachusetts thank you
both so much for all that you do to help
simplify and add value to people's lives
I have a few digital tools that have
helped me reduce the traffic of messages
and lists we so often lose or perhaps
miss manage on a daily basis the first
is Google key which is a sticky note
application to help you add dates and
times to remind you of upcoming tasks
that may not warrant a calendar invite
such as dropping off a letter or even
making grocery lists the notes can be
archived when they're done so it's less
of an inbox look to it although the
archives can be searched at a later time
if need be the second tool is called
unroll em II which is an email service
for most common email
writers and it shows you every list to
which your email is currently associated
once you give the service permission to
access your email I've used this service
for years by the way and I've had no
negative experiences with it and it's
free
you can unsubscribe from any and all
lists they're on this single site or you
can choose to keep them in your inbox
and lastly you can quote roll them up
into a single daily email from the
unroll that any famous perhaps coolest
of all is that it shows you when you're
added to new email lists so that it's a
sustainable resource to add to your life
the last tool is more of a shift in
behavior with respect to digital
activity so recently I removed all non
value-adding
applications and push notifications from
my phone and I began doing all of my
major work assignments first thing in
the morning at work as opposed to
checking email both of these behavior
switches have added tremendous time to
my life for valuable activities and help
put in both professional and personal
capacities hey guys first of all I just
want to say thanks and give you guys
encouragement I'm from Montana so it's
fun to hear Montana and positive light
and I appreciate the reader stories and
everything you guys do to make the
podcast go well but my wife when I
discovered this awesome game during our
purging we ended up with a pile of
negotiable items I call it the middle of
roulette or cage match or minimalistic
cage match basically my Velvet Elvis
painting versus my wife's striper vinyl
album or things of that nature we can
then both make a case for why we want to
keep that item and helps us talk through
the value process does it provide a
value added service or a value added
memory or etcetera what I defend this
item in family court it's a fun no
pressure way to process to what to keep
and what to let go of it really helps
each other ask each other questions and
bring out you know why should I keep
this and we actually did this with our
dogs toys as well we kind of left the
toys out to see which ones you were
interested in and we actually got our
dog in on the minimalism
and she's also a fan alright Joe thanks
again to dr. Christopher Ryan for
joining us this week I encourage you to
check out his new book civilized to
death and check out his podcast which I
absolutely enjoy all the time it is
called tangentially speaking you can
also find him on Twitter at that Chris
Ryan and real quick 4 right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists we talked
about this earlier but I just wanted to
reiterate it get your values worksheet
know what your values are over the
minimalists comm /v there's an essay
there called how to understand your
values and I list what all my current
values are how they've changed over the
years explain the whole process and you
can download it's a printable worksheet
so you can fill out your own values if
you like you can review them with other
people and I think you'll find a lot of
value in it if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for a podcast
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine oh by
the way that's the minimalist calm slash
V for that values workshop or you can
set a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm if you have a question
or comment or tip you can comment on
this episode though over at youtube.com
slash the minimalist if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists com
well never ever ever ever send you spam
or junk or sell your email address to
the Taliban maybe we should have like a
spam giveaway okay alright we will send
you our simple Sunday newsletter if you
want to get writings from the
minimalists for added value this week I
wanted to go back Ryan way way way back
Jesus in 2012 yeah all the way back then
before before we were so civilized speak
Macklemore and Ryan Lewis macklemore's
first album or their first album
together the best anti-consumerism song
I think I've ever heard is a song called
wings by Macklemore and Ryan Lewis it's
from their album The Heist and so I
would encourage you to check
it is the perfect it's the perfect
explanation of how we have civilized
ourselves to death
yeah and we were not complete unless I
buy this thing and I have this emblem I
have this logo on my shoe or my body I'm
not gonna be complete and it's a song
about that I've encourage you to check
that out it's called wings on the heist
album and if you leave here today with
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening yeah we'll see you next time
minimus